Corey the new guy his creepy mother a
useless sheriff and an inconsistent
Michael Myers there are so many
Halloween ends moments that fans just
couldn't get behind what would the
Halloween franchise be without the shape
waiting in the dark to strike this
franchise is the house that Michael
Myers built after all Halloween ends
does indeed live up to its promise of
ending the story that began with Lori
Strode over 40 years ago and it's clear
that the only way this Trilogy could
ever properly conclude is with a
showdown between Michael Myers and the
ultimate queen of scream however the
lead-up to the film's climax has proven
to be rather divisive and in some cases
completely confounding to audiences
while Michael makes a few brief
appearances in the midsection of the
film most of the story is focused on new
character Corey Cunningham we learned
that Corey's life was ruined in 2019 the
year after Michael's bloody return to
Haddonfield when he became involved in
the accident death of a boy he was
babysitting attempting to lead a normal
life in the years after proved
Impossible by sheer accident Corey finds
a kinship within Michael Myers and soon
becomes the monster the townsfolk have
made him out to be as a result most of
the film's bloodiest murders are enacted
by Corey not Michael as one Reddit user
asked anyone wish that Michael got more
screen time basically Michael's
signature murder spree was extremely
lacking in Halloween ends in fact some
other Reddit users compared the
experience to watching a John Wick film
and only seeing Keanu Reeves on screen
for 10 minutes
Michael Myers wasn't just a Scourge for
young babysitters 2018's Halloween and
Halloween kills also proved that he was
a holy Terror to the entire town of
Haddonfield it's no longer just Lori or
Lindsay who are living with trauma the
town has been saddled with the fear of a
killer coming for the innocent among
them so it stands to reason that the end
of Michael Myers would be cause for
celebration however what happens
following the Killer's demise is rather
odd at least according to fans at the
end of Halloween ends Lori stabs Michael
multiple times drops a fridge on him and
slits his throat she then straps him to
the roof of her car and parades him
through Haddonfield the townspeople and
the police immediately form a procession
and follow Lori to the junkyard they all
gather around and crowd surf Michael to
the junkyard Crusher Lori throws his
body in ensuring that All That Remains
of the shape is a pile of gory mush
nullifying any chance for a surprise
resuscitation as one Reddit user stated
parading him through the town the
townspeople marching was almost as bad
as the last movies the town fights
Michael together another user pointed
out that nobody seemed to notice the
teens who had been killed at the
junkyard earlier that night meanwhile
another redditor commented on the
absurdity of the procession occurring
under police escort Michael's death may
be a Triumph but the Macabre show
portrayed in Halloween ends is a bit of
a strange spectacle that for some feels
out of place while Corey had his fair
share of harassment from the people of
Haddonfield most would assume that his
mother would remain supportive however
Corey has a rather weird relationship
with his mom which shares some
commonality with Norman Bates I
understand
I don't hate her
I hate what she's become it's
established that Corey is 21 years old
yet some view his demanding mother as
pretty shocking and as for the full-on
mouth kiss she gives him at one point
some viewers have suggested their
relationship is as horrific as Michael
himself one redditor claimed their
relationship with Corey and his mom was
scarier than anything else in this movie
another redditor hilariously asserted
that kiss Disturbed me more than
anything Michael did in this Trilogy one
individual even noted the weird
commanding nature of Corey's mother
given that he is a grown man jokingly
one redditor recounted Corey's mother
berating him at the dinner table for
texting saying didn't know if I was
watching Halloween or psycho basically
fans seem to think there's something
very wrong about Corey's home life when
we first see Lori Strode in 2018's
Halloween she's paranoid armed to the
teeth and living in a gated compound for
four decades Lori had largely kept to
herself with the exception of the few
years she spent raising her daughter
Michael's torment had forever changed
Lori into a hardened survivalist she
actively prepared for the day Michael
would return assuming that he'd somehow
break free from imprisonment after a
long and grueling evening that resulted
in Lori losing her own daughter to
Michael's Rampage the shape disappeared
in the four years that followed Lori
appears to have found a new lease on
life she's no longer living in fear and
isolation instead residing with her
granddaughter Allison in a new home in a
residential area Lori's trajectory
certainly exudes emotional growth for
the Intrepid Hero however fans have also
pointed out that Lori's transformation
seems to occur in the wrong order with
one redditor writing Lori held a grudge
for 40 years while Michael was in
custody but four years after the death
of her daughter and disappearance of
Michael Myers has pivoted into an author
with an edgy side this is the time to be
paranoid it's 1978 and a Madman is on
the loose Sheriff bracket has been
briefed on Michael Myers by The Maniacs
psychiatrist Dr Loomis
I think you'll come back
I'm gonna wait for him Brackett actively
attempts to have the murderer cornered
and brought in eventually the police
succeed in detaining Michael as depicted
in a flashback sequence in Halloween
kills however the same can't be said for
modern day law enforcement throughout
all three of David Gordon Green's films
we are shown brief glimpses of sheriff
Barker but he never really seems to do
anything as far as the police force is
concerned we only witnessed the officers
with boots on the ground including Frank
Hawkins the sheriff couldn't control the
mob and kills and he never really thrust
himself headfirst into the search for
Michael Myers cheekily one redditor
wrote Sheriff Barker survived by pretty
much just staying away this whole time I
was so excited for that character when
he first showed up but he never really
did anything
Michael Myers noose with a bunch of nut
bags and hadn't filled on Halloween
night
however another user suggested that
maybe the sheriff had the right attitude
all along writing the smartest guy in
the whole trilogy knew what was up from
the get-go stayed out of the way
survived but if you ever need saving
from an actual serial killer don't call
Barker
Michael Myers is alive
Teen Angst and sexual escapades are
often the anchors of slasher horror
films however the most popular entries
in the Halloween franchise usually focus
more squarely on Michael Myers murderous
nature over the promiscuity of young
love after Allison's love interest met a
grisly end in Halloween kills Halloween
ends see sir befriending a new guy the
troubled Corey has clearly seen better
days and is in desperate need of human
interaction they quickly become more
than friends after connecting over their
shared traumas but their Whirlwind
romance has some fans questioning the
quality of the film's writing Corey is a
completely new addition to the trilogy
as such Alison and Corey aren't afforded
much screen time between murder sprees
to really flesh out their relationship
therefore many viewers were left feeling
like the love affair was a bit rushed
one redditor shared I could not buy
Corey and Allison's relationship one bit
she was all over him to an insane extent
another Reddit user replied it is
utterly bizarre how instant
Allison is falling over herself to throw
herself at Corey literally the second
she sees him walk into the clinic the
luck she gives him is so strange that I
initially thought it was implying that
the two characters already knew each
other or had some big history together
or were Old Flames basically many people
felt that everything about Corey seemed
rushed we've seen multiple Legacy
characters from the original 1978
Halloween movie reprized their roles
throughout David Gordon Green's Trilogy
however the fourth and final film adds
an entirely new leading character to the
narrative some viewers have asked
whether it was necessary to force Corey
into the mix when this finale could have
just focused on Lori and Michael's final
battle as one redditor quipped let's
make the last Halloween movie about some
dude that wasn't in any other movie
that'll be great another redditor
replied and let's give him more screen
time than any other character including
the main villain of the movie series
meanwhile one Twitter user ridiculed the
introduction of a new character saying
so glad that Halloween ends is finally
engaging with the franchise's most
iconic and beloved character Corey it
would seem that Corey's inclusion is
easily the most divisive aspect of
Halloween ends for a while it almost
felt like Corey was being primed to
become Michael Myers successor after
running into the shape hiding out in the
sewers of Haddonfield Corey manages to
avoid death at the hands of Michael a
quick Montage implies a supernatural
Union between the characters as though
Michael understands Corey has a
burgeoning Darkness within him the pair
even began killing together as Corey
seeks Vindication from those who have
wronged him but on Halloween night Corey
returns to the sewer and fights Michael
for his mask as Michael still doesn't
have his full strength Corey is somehow
able to best the murderer and leave with
the mask many found the moment rather
absurd though given that Michael
survived a Beatdown from a mob four
years ago only to Massacre everyone
right after so how exactly does Corey
best Michael in a physical confrontation
especially when we later see the serial
killer tossing Lori around the kitchen
in the Final Act of the film one
redditor States so Michael Myers who
survived multiple gunshot wounds stab
wounds and being burned alive get it's
his mask taken from him by a kid that
got beaten up by the marching band geeks
another user said it still blows my mind
how Corey literally bullied Michael and
took his mask
Halloween ends explores how evil can
corrupt those around us and after
enduring being shunned and tormented by
the townsfolk Corey decides to burn
Haddonfield to the ground and take his
turn as the shape while we're not meant
to condone his actions his reasons for
going down a dark path makes sense
what's less clear however is Corey's
reasoning for taking his own life after
unmasking Corey Lori tells him he can
never have Alison Corey Hears A Car
pulling up to the house and tells Lori
that if he can't have Alison then she
can't either he quickly plunges the
knife into his own neck hoping to imply
that Lori killed him forcing her to lose
Allison too discussing the strange
moment one redditor said this guy went
from meeting a girl to a day later
killing himself if he couldn't have her
another redditor replied Andy said that
if he can't have her no one can so why
would he kill himself and not her now
she is free to date anyone and he's too
dead to do anything about it Halloween
ends begins in 2019 only one year after
Michael Myers Bloody Rampage through
haddenfield the killer has since
vanished and the people of haddenfield
are irreparably damaged by Michael's
actions however Halloween festivities
appear to be proceeding as normal one
redditor pointed out the obvious writing
so in 2018 there was a riot at the
hospital and about 30 murders in
Haddonfield victims including kids
multiple cops and the entire fire
department the Killer is still at large
in 2019 its business as usual with
trick-or-treating and adults going out
to Halloween parties it's probably time
Haddonfield stopped celebrating
Halloween once and for all